so um and uh matthias did you did you
check if you can share screen
with us do you have co-hosts we can
can try that now let me just see if
it works see and
now i think
okay fantastic great okay so well
um welcome everybody to the to the
colloquium today um uh thanks brian for
this wonderful introduction
to to the field so it's a great pleasure
to have matthias troyer here from
from microsoft quantum where his
distinguished scientist
so matthias is um is probably
one of the world's leading computational
condensed matter physicists
um he's he's been off the raman prize
and the humber prize for theoretical
physics
but more to the point he spent many
years thinking about uh you know
think single-mindedly about how you can
get towards quantum advantage so it's a
great privilege to have matthias talk to
us about it please uh
yes thank you
and i got to the point where i said to
really make progress
i would love to have quantum hardware
because i know how to solve these
problems
really easily once they have a [ __ ] to
quantum your computer is so that's why
then join microsoft and in
the the meantime i've
to learn new jobs i've worked
on the cuban modeling
i've learned to work with customers
and now my new role is that of the
negative
systems here to the architect thinking
about what is needed to really build
the quantum computer and the basic
questions i'm asking today is what do we
need to really solve
practical problems of problems we're not
interested in
in with quantum hardware and the basics
is that new physics always leads to new
technologies
some of the dynamics led to the
invention of
the new
electromagnetism led
to negative electronics to computers
cell phones and much more and quantum
physics
is now more than
essentially old but we're only starting
to think about what
else could we do with quantum
systems and what i'm interested in is
what they call a practical quantum
advantage so i'm interested
in really solving a useful problem
that is useful either academically or
for negative industry faster better
on a quantum computer than on any known
classical computer
i'm not interested in saying is this
quantum annealer
10 times slower faster than than than
then then
[Music]
i'm not interested in whether some
random circuit can be done better on
quantum hardware
than classical one but i really want to
solve a problem
a problem that interests somebody and
they want to do it better than on any
classical computer kind of things where
say hey
we know we can't do it classically but
quantumly we can that's really
the interesting application and that's
why it's worth
investing in building the quantum
hardware
and when you then listen to people
there's a maze of
proposed applications one reads lots in
the media
about how quantum computers will help
with big data how they will cure cancer
design new drugs proteins predict
the stock market and so there are loads
of things where people claim that
this is all what quantum will solve but
looking at that
for each of these days always one of the
the the
known quantum gear algorithm that can
somehow be applied
but this looks more to me i said like
the hope for a quantum wishing well
these are all the hard problems for
which i want a solution
and we would need to see now what of
those problems can really be tackled by
quantum computers
and the starting point of course is a
quantum algorithm
with quantum your speedup and the most
com
apprehensive your list is on the
quantum algorithm
but by stephen jordan but then that is
only the start
because most of the work on algorithm so
far
in the past has been on complexity
theoretics so it is
the asymptotic scaling when the problem
size gets big
enough the complexity increases
slower quantumly than classically
but in order to really realize that i
want to go
to a problem size where quantum is
faster than classical
for small problems classical is faster
because it's simple and cheaper
to build the clock hazard faster and
it's only for the big sizes where
quantum will win
and i want to look at the cost of a size
where the cost of it happens
and the time because i care about
solving a problem in a few weeks and not
in a millennium
not asymptotically and so the question
is what are the problems where the cost
of a time
can be short enough that it could be
practical in the next decades
and for that i now want to compare
a classical system with a quantum system
i want to totally bias it towards the
quantum system
i want to say let me put in the race on
the classical side
a single of today's classical chip the
most advanced
nvidia
want to say let's take one of those and
quantumly i envision that in some time
we'll build a machine with 10 000
logical qubits
fast ones with a logical cycle time of
a few microseconds let me ignore data
movement by assuming that with some
matching
will manage all to
all their connectivity and i want to
compare those two to see
what could this future quantum computer
do better than a single classical chip
that i can just buy today
and there i want to start
and debunk some hype
one thing when often hears is quantum
computers will solve the big data
problem
but when you look at that quantum
compute in the class single one the
classical chip can read
10 terabit a second the quantum computer
with 10 thousand cubits at the clock
speed of your
to to ten microseconds can read about
one gigabit a second
so that future quantum machine is about
a factor ten thousand slower
for classical i o than today's classical
computer
and thus it is very clear to all i think
just looking at that
it's not for big classical data but
quantum computers will excel
on big compute problems on small data
or maybe on problems on quantum data
that we have to find
but then mentioning that one often also
hears that
quantum realm qram will solve this
and i've tried to understand that and
the
the the quality helped me understand
what qm is about
how it speeds things up and the way i
like to
present it in a simplified way and
that's something we
can talk about later
is basically the idea behind qrm is in
taking the classical computer
with the i o system and putting
everything
into a quantum domination position
so the idea of this qram oracle
is in a simplified way you take a hard
disk
and you can read all the data at once
basically by putting the
read head of the hard drive in
a quantum reasonable position of all the
locations
on the disk and to
anybody who builds mechanical quantum
systems or
organic quantum devices is clear the
the dissipation will stop that
this is not scalable because it's analog
there's
this noistic coherence and it is a
beautiful theoretical idea
but really implemented will need
negative negative
quantum your correction
and then the scaling goes back to be
proportional to the data size
it would be great if somebody could make
that really
rigorous and give us a bound on what it
takes
in a default tolerant way but that's why
we're saying
i really want to focus on the small data
problems that are hard to compute
and there then the neath way of saying
it it is quantum these are faster
because
they can explore exponentially many
inputs at once
but we know all it's it's not that easy
because while it can
get uh to
compute in
the position i need more than that
because i need to be able
to read out the results
and when i just look at the answer then
i get just
some random output that won't help me
and so we need to go beyond that and one
way of extracting the data would be with
grover search governs algorithm
with a quadratic speed up over the
classical computing so it may not
be
extra differentially faster
but in many cases we can get at least
a quadratic speed up and so i want
to look into how do the numbers work out
by comparing
that classical chip with the future
quantum computer
and today's classical chip are amazingly
fast
the cheap
per second
numbers or it could do about five
better op for logical operations and if
i built an asic with
the same pair of your transistors then
it could be a bit faster
on the quantum computer if i want to do
a logical operation then i can do about
a few million operations per second if
you want to do
a floating point operation then
assuming all assuming that i ignore
all the cost of data movement and layout
ignoring all the overhead
of reversible computation the peak
performance that it could get is a few
thousand operations per second so we see
just comparing a single classical chip
with a
future 10 000 logical cube bit quantum
machine
the quantum machine is 10 to 12 orders
of magnitudes
slower than the classical one but
there's a constant
slow down the quantum machine will then
win with quantum speed up because it
scales better as we go
to larger systems but if we now think
about it
i can overcome that constant slowdown
because i have to make fewer calls to an
orbital
but if the constant slowdown is about 10
to the 12 then have to make 10 to the 12
fewer calls
that means with quadratic speedup i
start winning
if quantumly and make 10 to the 12 calls
versus classically 10 to the 24
or with cubic speed up it looks a bit
better it's a million versus your 10 to
the 18.
but you need to make 10 to the 12 times
fewer call because the machine is a
constant about 10 to the 12 slower
and now you can turn that around and ask
if we have quadratic speed up what is
the time we need to do that
and i think one can see it right here
the time to do 10 to the 24 operations
is years or months at least
so quadratic speedup may not be enough
and i turned it around
and said how many operations can i do in
one call
to the oracle so that the crossover time
is not more than about than a few weeks
and the answer is simply with floating
point operations
i can't get there with the assumptions i
made
on the quantum machine and a single
classical one
i just can't have it but if i have a
very simple arc
with just a few up to nine seventy two
logical operations then with those
assumptions the quantum machine might
win
we're still very optimistic for quantum
pessimistic for classical and so i'd say
clearly we need more than quadratic
speedups quadratic speedups are
beautiful
in theory but if we want to build a
machine
and calculate something faster than
classically
then i will need more than quadratic
speedups
if we go to cubic speedups they can a
bit more
20 000 operations so i think that's when
it starts getting interesting
and when i want to look at what is now
the real cost of doing that
on the quantum machine and couldn't
solve the problem by just having 100
gpus so really we want
exponential speedups that's where we
have the best chance
so from that whole list of problems
that one often hears i like to drop out
all of the problems that are big data
problems
machine learning problems weather
prediction stock market this is all tied
to the data
and the proposals for problems like
protein folding
and drug design are also often tied to
grover speed up
so those that like to drop out and i
really think we need to focus on the
algorithms with exponential speed up
and what do we have to
that we can do there one problem is
factoring
then i'm not that interested in
factoring numbers there's not a
great application where i solve a real
problem but there are
the other problems
where that
that i'm getting interested in and where
there can also be exponential quantum
speed up
and those are problems of
quantum systems
simulating quantum systems when i
simulate
a simple molecule like caffeine
then i can't do it
exactly brute force but with the the
methods you mentioned in
the tutorial
we have good enough classical
approximations that let me
simulate a molecule
[Music]
i can predict this properties it works
but there are other molecules like here
i mentioned
the the the negev mocha
complex where we don't have any known
classical algorithm that
can calculate it well enough
so there are these problems in chemist
and in material science where
we have no way of solving them to the
level we want to get to on a classical
computer
but where quantum computer can do it
one example also is a leafy screen when
you look outside the spring and the
leaves come up then
you see the green everywhere so nature
knows the leaf is green
but calculating the color of chlorophyll
is hard classically and why is that
it is because nature is quantum and
classical computers are not
and that's why why [ __ ] feinman
decades back said really to to
to simulate your quantum physics to
to to simulate your quantum problems
we we need quantum hardware we should
think of
a computer that
works on quantum mechanic principles as
we all know
and they already exist
in some way because the first such
machines were
analog just like in the classy world
where the
the [ __ ] first computer
disney world again analog ones was
so
soon so so quantumly
people started their building here
simulators
for the special purpose
machine that could solve yours
certainly quantum models already more
than a decade ago
for example you think yes this thing is
like
cold cold cold
where people take an atom
in a trap shown on
the left here
the the the
the
the more lasers
to it and build a special purpose
computer analog one
to really build that model in the lab
and measure things on it and with that
one can do models that are hard
classically
but how do we know whether it works or
not
so the first thing done was really one
takes a model
that one knows how to the
to to to dissolve classically and
test it and validate it
and and
that this is something we've done
in a lattice we
simulated that classically we simulated
it
on the quantum device analog
and we compared and we wanted to show
that it
and the answer was of course at first it
didn't agree at all it was just nonsense
and then we looked closer and we
realized that
it did not agree because we didn't
really understand what was built but
once we understood
how the the
quantum gear calculator worked then we
got to
this picture the back row
are the classic results the front row
the quantum results i have showed
the negative
[Music]
the more
distribution function of bosons in the
lattice
left is cold right it's hot that hot
there's a
there's a there's there's a there's
some there's no feature
at low temperatures when you cool down
you see at some point here
the secondary peak appears and that's
where the both gas
forms a so-called bose sega engineer
condensate
and the agreement between the the
quantum mechanic simulation in the
front row and the classic one is really
great
so those systems work we can build
non-trivial
quantum simulators that solve certain
quantum models
and then you can go to problems that are
hard classically
you can go to fermions
or you can go to dynamics
and here's in the
example of
a 10 year old paper that shows a quench
in uh one dimensional gas sofia
bosons the classical calculation here
to stop off
a while since
once continue now here there's not much
features in there it equilibrates
basically
but on the seas there could be models
where dynamics
we can go to points that are classically
hard but
quantumly achievable and
there is an advantage of quantum
hardware over classical one
that is analog and just like
classical machines that are analog
it is limited one limitation is it is
hard to cool it down
to low temperatures a second problem of
anything
think negative analog is precision
the calibration precision the
measurement precision
one can get did you calibrate it
to a percent a bit better but not more
and that is the same reason why in
classical computing
we switched from analog to digital
just because when it's analog we cannot
really
calibrate it well enough to scale we
cannot
ever to correct it but digital we can
and so the same has to happen quantumly
to go
to a broader class of models really
scale up to make it more precise
we can need a gate model i call it
digital
quantum computer that can
be negat where you're corrected
and so with that now i want to see kind
of what is one of the simplest quantum
models
that i could simulate where a gate model
machine
could give me a quantum advantage so how
can i do something that if
that one is the done
in the negative the analog way and go
beyond it
by doing it digitally and
one of the simplest problems here that
we've looked at
that
team members was to look at
how many quantum gates and qubits do i
need to get to a point where it's
classically hard
but where could do it analog and what is
needed
in a gate model approach and
in contrast to previous work we didn't
look at what we need to get the wave
function
to a certain the the the fidelity i get
more about properties i can measure
so we said what do we need to get the
measurements
of certain local properties to the same
point that they could do it
do it in then
experiment and then strongly relaxed
the the conditions but we find still
that for it to be hard i need to do much
more than about
50 that the the quantum particles
and in this case we looked at the
quantum magnet at transverse field
field again the the icm single model
and we said we need to look at least at
10 times 10 lattice so so about 100
quantum spins
which could be about the 100 cubits
that's where it gets hard classically
64. so i could still do kind of
classically approximately
nine times nine might get hard so we we
could choose
nine or ten i've chosen ten here and
then i need to propagate it for a
certain time
and the time has to be at least as long
as
the linear extent of the lattice or the
system would not even see the size
so that's right that's als so so if i'm
choosing a two-dimensional lattice and
not
a one-dimensional chain because in a 1d
chain
i would have to propagate for a time of
100
to see the system size so here i'm
choosing a 10 times 10 system and then
propagating it for a time of 10.
to describe it i need just 100 cubits
and then to accurately mostly do it with
a high fatality in the simulation i
would need a very small time step
but what we found is if i relax the
condition and say i just want to
simulate it well enough
that is comparable to experiments
and compared to the precision they could
get from measurements in experiments
given an unavoidable
calibration error of about the the
the the the negative
you can actually take pretty large time
steps and then we found that one can do
the simulation 100 qubits in just a few
10 000 gate operations
so this is great news because this is
far smaller
than what was here to the thought before
that that with [ __ ] 30 000
coffee gate operations we could get to
the point where i'm doing something that
is classically hard but doing 30
000 gate operations
still means the error on every single
gate operation has to be less
than negative one in a million or the
result will just
be random noise and so this is still way
beyond
the
in this card where i really need
to do the
default tolerance and then we estimate
we need about 100
000 physical qubits to do that but so
with one hundred thousand physical
qubits
and uh
and like
tolerant assimilations we can solve
quantum problems
that are classically hard that's not so
far out i think we
that can be achieved in
the next years
so let me now next go from from this
simplest problem
to a really interesting problem that is
here
to commercially impactful and see what
is needed there
and the problem there is one in
chemistry and i want
to to look at the problem
on negativity catalysis
and we did a case study on a catalyst
for the
for negative carbon fixation so we want
to for example find a material
that that that
helps us yet take technical
co2 from the atmosphere and turn it into
methanol
and in order to do that one can either
try out
many different catalysts or we can try
to predict
how they work through calculation
and for that we have to go through the
reaction
cycle so on the left here
i have have the the
the the [ __ ] catalyst
to react with the
the [ __ ] cup and get directed molecule
it binds
it goes goes two steps
depends
here
and then the catalyst again binds with
the next molecule but for that to work
really this reaction cycle has to be the
dominant one
we don't want it to just to
go
be stuck with it find the catalyst
plug it up but we really want that just
this cycle happens
and so we want to be able to predict and
calculate it
before we start and make the catalyst
and in order to do that i have to look
at all possible directions in which
things could go
have to look at all possible product
state all possible
the reaction pathways
and then i look at the energy along
the reaction and as they bind and react
there's a barrier
and the rate for the reaction is
exponential
in the energy height of the barrier
divided by the temperature
so in order to know in which direction
things react
i have to look at all possible paths
calculate the energies of these barriers
and then find out which varia is lowest
and then i'm calculating the reaction
rates
and then i hope that these barriers on
this path that they want to achieve
are the lowest order to do that i need
to know these energy differences i need
to know
the barrier heights here during the
reactions
and they need to know it accurate they
need to know it accurate compared to the
temperature
because if the accuracy is much much
less than the temperature then it
really just don't know where it goes so
it has to be at least
the temperature and so in this context
you have to
chemically accuracy as mentioned in the
the tutorial means i have to be able to
calculate the energy
better than the temperature
and the challenge here is that the
temperature is an energy scale
that's typically a million times smaller
than the total energy of a molecule
so if to really be able to calculate the
energy to six seven
eight digits of precision
and many of the classical methods that
were mentioned in
the the the the
the tutorial are then not good enough
so that's where quantum computers come
in
and it comes in into workflow where i'm
exploring
possible structures and then for these
structures i want to solve the problem
on quantum hardware or i want to solve
it in some way
but classically it's not good enough and
quantumly
i can't read brute force because the
molecule is too big
so what one then does is one looks at
the
it's the
where
solves that problem on quantum hardware
and then
one feeds it back to
the classical calculation looks at
pathways
finds new candidates and loses to that
so we'll want to do
many calculations of that of
accurate energies of the quantum system
and to do that we're using the quantum
phase estimation so we'd like to know
the spectrum
and especially the ground state and
maybe
the
and but all i can do on
the quantum hardware is i can
can i guess simulate the the the
dynamics of a
quantum system and so i want to
implement
the the time evolution of a quantum
system
and if you combine that with phase
estimation
then by measuring the phase the wave
function picks up
i can get the energy because the phase
picked up by
an eigenstate is proportional to the
energy of the state at a time
and thus by measuring the phase with
phase estimation
i can get the energy of the state
and so it boils down ultimately to time
evolution
of a quantum state under
the hamiltonian the energy function that
describes the molecule
and i've shown before how for the
quantum
magnet that was super easy in the
chemistry problem it's
it's a bit harder because the model is
more complex
and the model and the reason why it's
more complex is
that the the the coulomb interaction
between electrons is long range
and so when i have two electrons
and when i write down the model for
foreign
then the number of terms in the model is
n to the power four
from a complexity
that is theory viewpoint one is one
because the number
of terms the terms is
for each term i have an e f if
the efficiently circuit to implement it
so the scaling is
polynomial but the scaling with n to the
four number of terms scares me
scares me even classically and so the
question is
is it really efficient in a practical
sense can i really do it well
what will it take to do it or are the
constants so large
that it might be hard and when we first
looked at that
it it indeed
looked hard it looked bad when we took
the
implemented it and estimated the runtime
then with the the assumptions we have
now of
a clock speed speed at the logical
level of microseconds but there would be
about a billion years
and a billion years is beyond the few
weeks that they want to wait
we can't wait that long but then
then with [ __ ] tastings
that they've reckoned others we improved
the implementations
and brought the cost down by effect
the reason why four years back we said
it could be a month is that we assumed
optimistically
a future machine might be fast and might
have a clock speed of nanoseconds
we now realize it's more
more than a microsecond so we say the
runtime of those algorithms was about a
century
much better than a billion years but
still too slow but then in
the last three years we bought it
done father now we think that with about
5000 logical qubits
we can do it in in roughly a month and i
want to mention
two of the advances that led to that
and the first advance is rethinking the
problem we want to solve
we want to know the energies
and so it can time and we want to know
the wave functions so the eigen states
and for that they want to time evolve
with the model
the hamiltonian and that just takes time
one breakthrough here was that realizing
if i don't care about
the exact exact neurodynamics but i care
about
the spectrum then i can't do the
calculations
for the for negative any function
of the hamiltonian
and it turns out that the time
revolution under
the negative to the arc sign of h is
much more efficient to implement
than under the gap
itself and so a big step forward here
was
realizing that i can propagate with a
certain function of age
that makes it more efficient to get the
the negative the spectacle
the information and so the run time
comes down
per time step the next thing we do
is we have enter the four terms but the
question is do we really
need negative that many
and so the next breakthroughs over
the last years was looking at sparse
representation can i
look at those terms and write down a
sparse representation a sparse model for
it
that has fewer terms but still has this
same
accuracy and that worked
and not only did the the
biography of the terms go down we also
can make the time steps larger because
of that
and so so we can do
fewer time steps and each one is faster
and that let us
bring down the cost but i think we're
slowly reaching
limits here because we're really
thinking about what is really the
minimal information that they need to
describe the chemistry problem and it's
still a small one
so there's still more breakthroughs
needed here
and i believe the next breakthroughs
really have to come also from chemistry
let me look at a second example for that
to get to illustrate why i want to look
at
a problem here again a catalyst
for nitrous
the gene fixation there are certain
enzymes in microbes
in the soil that can
which is the basis here the
the fertilizers to understand how it
works
you wouldn't principal have to look at
that big enzyme
with about the thousand electrons and
that problem with the scaling
it's just far too big that you can ever
do it put forth
quantumly it's super big you have the
classically even and so what then does
is one looks really at
the the active center the core of it and
there is
this negative cofactor that
i mentioned at them
that i i mentioned
earlier and then we want to focus just
at the center of it
and just add a small active space of a
few interesting orbitals
but as we do that we have a problem
because we took looking at the big
molecule and then we're making a model
just for this tiny active center
really truncating the model to just a
tiny bit of the molecule
and we throw out the rest and the
problem one has there is that this
restriction to the active space to the
center
incurs an uncontrolled error so then
we're using the quantum computer
to totally precisely and accurately
calculate the energy
of a model that itself has an
uncontrolled error that might be bigger
than the temperature
so the problem here is really how do i
do this embedding
how do i simulate this big molecule
accurately if you can say
can can look at a tiny piece of it
do that quantumly exactly
but how do i now make sure that the
truncation error of getting to that
problem
does not make the exactness of the
the the quantum gear simulation
irrelevant so we have to solve this
problem
with
[Music]
actions with uh
to the rest of the system and that is a
problem that we need to start solving
now
because unless we solve it the exact
energy from
quantum hardware will not really take us
all the way
and the good news is being motivated by
this and starting to work on solving
that problem in new ways
because of the motivation from quantum
can help us classically even before we
have
the year thousands of qubits needed to
solve the chemistry problem
i want to end by showing one of the area
where the same thing happened because
when we talk about
quantum and quantum impact
cryptographies one simulation is the
other but you also for a long time when
talked
about negative the
optimization there are many different
problems
hard problems where
diagnosis oil and gas material discovery
power kits signal processing
machine learning scheduling logistics
traffic whatever
there are loads of problems where
we want to solve a hard op
timization problem and the hope was that
using quantum effects
one can more still
escape from a local minimum
and instead of climbing over the barrier
one can just quantum tunnel through it
and that that was
the the the
the motivation for
and there have been cases that one
can build and construct where the
quantum tunneling is exponentially
better than climbing over the barrier
but what we realized over the last
decade looking at
quantum annealers is that you can mimic
it classically you can simulate it
efficiently classically and so you can
mimic
the quantum tunneling on a classical
computer
and thus what that led to is a quantum
inspired algorithm
where basically one takes the ideas of
the quantum algorithm when d
quantizes it and one turns the quantum
algorithm into a related
classical algorithm that the
that with mega monte carlo
sampling gives us much of
the speed up from the
quantum yeah algorithm
classical hardware and so that this year
the one example we're thinking about
quantum algorithms
and how we use them gave us new ideas
foreign
and one example was we
sequences
that reduce the scan time by factor
three which is make a big breakthrough
there
and similarly
i predict that the breakthrough we make
in chemistry
by thinking about quantum will lead
to breakthroughs there even before we
have
the quantum hardware scaled up and so to
end now
what i've been trying to show today is
that to really
get quantum advantage for a practical
problem in the next decades
we need to focus on a problem that has
small data
to be compute problems and to really
beat the classical hardware we have
we need to look for problems with more
than quadratic speed up
even the simplest application problems
problems will need negative the
tolerance the hundreds of years
thousands of cubits to beat
the the
best
classical algorithms once we get to
millions there are loads of your
chemistry problems that will solve
the interesting one like the carbon
fixation
and more that's where they can help
but even on the way there in the
decade it takes us to get there there
will be breakthroughs
in classical methods just
from tackling the classical chemistry
problems we need to solve to make
the quantum hardware useful so
on the way to building the million gig
qubit machine will have lots of progress
from quantum computing on classical
hardware
thank you great uh
thanks um thanks matthias for a great
talk
um actually i was very um you know it
was very interesting to
uh to see that um your very pragmatic
view about
um about uh quantum advantage in quantum
algorithms
sort of coincided with the complexity
theoretic view where
where we always look for super
polynomial or exponential speed ups
you know rather than polynomial speed
ups which we treat treat as being
somewhat suspicious so it's
it's actually very interesting that the
two ends of this spectrum agree more
than the middle
um so um let's let's open it up to uh
some questions before we get to the
panel um
so
[Music]
let's see is
let's see if do any of the
the moderators have
i actually had a in the meantime had a
had a question
um you know where at the beginning of
your talk you
um you sort of um
you know you had these calculations uh
you know saying that
um that the clock speed of a quantum
computer would necessarily be
um you know many orders of magnitude
slower than a
than a classical computer so is that um
is is is that a is that a practical
consideration currently or is that
is there something inherently true about
it even looking
somewhat far into the future so i think
this can likely be improved with
breakthroughs
in
you're correcting codes but i think
it is fundamental and the reason is that
at the lowest level i physically qubits
and i have to control the physical
qubits i have to do
the physical gait operations and that
needs a classical computer to control
and to do demand
the manipulation of the quantum state
and if you then
on top of that do the negative the
centromere mesh the main cycles
so that then things slow down because
let's say for
a surface code and i need a code
distance of maybe about
20 or 30 and each cycle is about
10 gates to implement so i have a few
hundred
gate operational cycles that i do and
thus i have i am at least
effect of a few hundred slower than the
classical computer that controls the
physical gate operations
then i also have the space overhead of
quantum
correction and if i take a code distance
of 20 in a surface code
then it means i need about a thousand
physical qubits for a logical qubit
okay it might have
the
the the the more physically cubist and
logical cubits
with that i'm about the defect or a
hundred thousand
and then the qubit is just much more
complex than a transistor
so the classic logic i need to actually
control the qubit is effective 100 000
bigger so then i have my next factor of
100.
and so so just from simple applications
and now the factor
100 million already
i see that that's really illuminating um
and then is the size
on that chip i can really squeeze tiny
transistors i don't know if you can make
the qubits so small
and fit that many on a single wafer so
so and that's then the the next vector a
thousand is
is kind of the density or the size of
the physical qubit
compared to the size of the transistor
so i think the the i think if the
breakthroughs really comes on the
classical side with the classical
control then it will profit also the
classical computing
the breakthrough has to come in either
much better qubits
or in new qec codes that could maybe
give us a breakthrough or both
that's how we can shave off of that
great um
can i ask a question yes please yes
you're right
so just i just wanted to make sure i
understood
your discussion of the transfers field
yep eisen model
so one i just want to make sure i i got
the basics right so you were saying that
a 10 by 10 system with 100 cubits
30 000 gate operations did i understand
correctly that you thought that that was
within
reach on the scale of a year was that no
no no okay so
so i said this is something that is just
beyond what i can do classically i don't
think
i can do it accurately to that position
of about a percent
for the prediction over that time on a
classical computer
any classic algorithm that can get us
there no no my question was on
on a nisk device and then
the nisk device if you if i need to do
30 000 rotation gates
accurately and i want to have result
this accurate
to 99 percent then i need a fidelity on
my cubist that is about
seven nines on the gate operations and
because i want to do
about 50 000 gate operations and
then you have to er error rate should be
less
than one percent and so you need another
per gate operation
of less than the one in a few million
and i'm saying that nisk machines don't
currently have any roadmap towards that
but we need fault tolerance
okay maybe i should have asked the
question more stupidly
what do you think might be possible with
this devices and the transdustrializing
model let me ask the question that way
yeah this device is on the transfer
reverse field ic model on a size that
i can't read classically yes i know you
love the model
let's take 100 spins and then per time
step
you need to have at least one rotation
gate per
term and so you say per time step we
need about 300
or about a thousand gate operations say
for one time step
and with three nice fidelities that
means i can do one time step
and things start to randomize and once
one time step we can still do
classically
but when you can go for ten time steps
and you can
can choose a big time step then it
becomes hard classically
right so i'd say on this
devices
i want to change my answer and say if
you insist on using it like a digital
machine if you're using an analog
quantum system and now you insist that
you only have
the discrete gate operations of a
digital computer
then you combine the disadvantages of
analog
be noisy and digital being restricted
what you should actually do is you
should take the analog machine
and use it as an analog machine and then
you can do loads
so so if you use the qubit
and just view it as an analog quantum
simulator
then there are many people here or so
in the the audience who've done that for
decades and and that and there you can
do it to a lot
and that was even done recently
by by
to wave on their systems
when they started to look at their
machine as an analog simulator for an
icing model
then they can do interesting work there
but when you you look at the nisk
machine that's my point of view now
as an analog machine and you use it like
a gate model machine then you are
handicapping the device
the disk kit gates it becomes useful
once you have fault tolerance you need
it for that
[Music]
so nist devices have already for a long
time
solved nice icing models in an analog
way
you don't need to wait a year you can
have it now
um quickly i think uh ike trung has a
question thanks sumesh and thank you
matthias for a wonderful talk
and my question is about the second half
of your talk
you mentioned having breakthroughs for
maybe devices and quantum error
correction but
how about device how about breakthroughs
based on asking better questions
and specifically i noticed that you're
still focusing on
eigenvalue estimation using phase
estimation
but in your beautiful work with
microsoft and guangzhou
and so forth on this new singular value
transform algorithm
it allows you to ask more sophisticated
questions like polynomial transforms of
the eigenvalue spectrum as you know very
well
yeah can you think of better questions
that take advantage of that so that you
ask a big
quantum question and then transform the
system so you can answer that all at
once
that's it so here basically we have
transformed the problem using
those those those tricks of your grand
cow and others
and yours kind of to say we can
transform the problem to make it easier
to solve
and but then we still looked at the
energy of the spectrum
the the bigger question is are there any
practical applications for quantum
algorithms that we have
not thought about yet or chemically
relevant
polynomial transformed questions like
reaction rates or thresholds or asking
about
ranges of eigenvalues instead and
i i know this is an extended question
and i don't want to get into the panel
time too long but
maybe if you have a brief answer so the
brief answer is basically
for reaction rates the simulator often
boils down to energies
and for energies you run in to
the nigerian
so that the time you need to do
something
to get it to a certain level is bounded
from below
and that's likely the answer without
that you could maybe
be avoid heisenberg and so there might
be a way
to reformulating that in the question
can we prove a lower bound on that or
or can can by breaking through lower
bounds in some smart way
one could have ideas how to get the
energies better
great thank you okay well thanks
thanks again matthias that was that was
a great
uh colloquium so now we move on to